Speaker 1: Let's take a spin through the
campaign trail and the last 24 hours. A
number of former Democratic presidents out
on the campaign trail hoping to stem losses,
hoping to create wins, hoping to turn maybe
at least a couple of elections. One of those
individuals is former President Barack Obama.
Former President Barack Obama really stung
Cory Lake and by extension, Donald Trump by
pointing out we've tried electing people who
are just known for being on TV and it didn't
go particularly well. Reports are many on the
right particularly upset by what Barack Obama
said yesterday during an event in Arizona in
support of Democrats running in that state.
Speaker 4: Here in Arizona, there's no question
that that Katie Hobbs, his opponent, she's good
in front of the camera because she's been doing
it for a long time. Right. So some people don't
know this, but apparently Kerry Lake actually
interviewed me back in 2016 when I was president.
True. She was she was a local news anchor. She was
doing her job at the time. I don't remember
thinking that she was the kind of person who
would push debunked COVID remedies or promised
to issue a declaration of invasion at our border.
Speaker 1: That's a very important action.
Speaker 4: Or a claim without any evidence
that the 2020 election was stolen. I
guess that stuff came later because
she found it convenient. Indeed. Well,
here's an opportunity to get attention.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 4: Let's
listen in. If we hadn't just elected somebody
whose main qualification was being on TV,
you could see. Maybe give it a shot.
What's the worst that could happen? Well,
now we know. Yeah, it doesn't just work
out just because some of these men on TV.
Speaker 1: President Obama is is is quite good
at this. And indeed, he is needed in Arizona. And
the reason that he is needed in Arizona is just
look at the polling. Cory Lake is an individual
who has no business whatsoever in public service.
She talked about Arizona seceding from the United
States. She spreads the big lie. She said she was
taking prophylactic ivermectin on and on and on.
And she is I don't even want to say potentially. I
think at this point we have to say if you believe
the polling, she is the most likely heir apparent
to become the governor of Arizona. Currently, Kari
Lake is leading Democrat Katie Hobbs by an average
of 2.8 now. What's going on with the polling?
Do we believe these numbers? I don't know. We
will have a report either tomorrow or Monday
about the allegations of bad polling, unreliable
polling and push polling related to the election.
But why chance it? Why chance it? 2.8?
Maybe she's winning by 2.8. Maybe it's
a tie or not. Your vote really matters this
time around. And for everybody who says, Well,
what? What do you mean? My vote. It's never
it never comes down to one vote. Here's the
way you have to think about that. How often does
the election come down to one vote? Very rarely.
But a lot of people say that to themselves. A lot
of people say, why do I need to vote? It never
comes down to one vote. If all the people who
thought that stayed home, it would actually flip
elections. And that's why it's important when you
say to yourself, it never comes down to one vote,
why do I need to vote? Understand that there
are thousands or tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of other people saying the same thing
to themselves. If you all stay home, one candidate
wins. If everybody who has that, that votes, the
other candidate wins. So do not allow yourself to
fall into that thinking. One other funny Barack
Obama clip from the Arizona rally talking about
Blake Masters, that really bizarre dude who's
running against Mark Kelly and also who might
win. Just very funny commentary about him.
Speaker 4: If you were trying to create.
In a lab? Yes. A wacky Republican politician.
It looked a lot like this guy.
Speaker 5: That.
Speaker 4: Mr. Masters drew campaign backed
by a tech billionaire who's questioning
the value of democracy.
Speaker 1: Right. Got it.
Speaker 4: Wants to give tax cuts
to big corporations that are jacking
up prices on consumers.
Speaker 3: Of course, Jeff.
Speaker 4: Thinks it's a good idea to privatize
Social Security and, quote, cut the knot
on the benefits that more than a million seniors
here in Arizona depend on. Check, check, check.
Unidentified: And I got a little fired up.
Speaker 4: About this the other day in
Wisconsin. But it's true here in Arizona, too.
Folks in Arizona have Social Security, not
because somebody is giving it to them as a payoff,
as a as a gift. They earned it. You paid for it?
Speaker 1: That's exactly right. And the Social
Security issue is increasingly becoming
an issue. Very good appearance by former
President Barack Obama. He was not the only
former president out on the campaign trail.